well it's a very merry breakfast at
Legoland California as they bring the
Lego cheer to the holidays Mercedes
talked with Jake from Legoland to find
out how you can be part of the holiday
festivities
Legoland California Resort is bringing
the holiday spirit to Carlsbad and we
have our friend Jake back what a winter
wonderland behind you Jake I love it yes
it is a winter wonderland here at
Legoland California Resort as the
holidays have officially kicked off here
and we are excited for families to come
out come and enjoy our Christmas tree
enjoy all the new shows and
entertainment that's going to be going
on throughout January 8th uh for
everybody to enjoy
I love that you're saying Merry brick
Miss because it's all about the bricks
everywhere I love the Snowman behind you
and and that's there's a bunch of
festive zones that you have correct
a bunch of Festival zones we have a wide
variety of zone so from the moment you
walk into the park into peppermint Plaza
you're gonna be able to hear our mint
marching band enjoy our jingle Jamboree
head up to our Wizards uh Winter Hill
enjoy some a very Merry Christmas uh you
know show up there and huffit snow here
in Carlsbad California and then head
over to Tinseltown mistletown to uh to
enjoy some fun here which is in our fun
town area of our park to enjoy some more
festive music enjoy some new shows very
very mix up with our Mrs Claus and her
elves and then go and enjoy some of the
Savory treats and sweet treats that we
have throughout the park for everybody
to have fun and enjoy I'm glad you
brought up the treats because I have
been checking out some of the amazing
things that you have like peppermint
bubble gum ice cream and and rice
pudding and Crepes but there's something
that really caught my eye can you tell
me a little bit about this firework
churro the firework show yes it's Kyle
liver that that's sweet and spicy to it
so it really just melts in your mouth
when you enjoy it I me being a fan of
churros I love them and then you know
what the best part is to wash it down
with our new Yeti monster milkshake
which actually comes with many little
Donuts on it has this really cool blue
raspberry flavor all the way through it
it is delicious
oh man I cannot wait
until they get a ticket
best thing to do is to go and make
reservations go on to legoland.com you
can make your hotel reservations we have
our Legoland hotel and Legoland Castle
Hotel that are fully themed in a holiday
you know Decor uh and then get yourself
ready to come right into the park the
hotels are steps away from the park but
go to legoland.com to find out more
information also to set up your trip if
you want to come out for the largest
kids New Year's Eve party which is here
at the park for guests to enjoy our
fireworks started exploding at 7 p.m so
kids can still make their bedtime just
in time for the new year but a lot of
festivities going on throughout the rest
of the year all the way till January 8th
but also enjoy uh the kids New Year's
Eve festivities as well but for all that
information go to legoland.com
I love that you're doing the whole thing
fireworks too thank you so much Jake so
good to see you and merry brick Miss to
you Merry Christmas and happy holidays
we look forward to seeing you